good morning John and good morning to
all of the people who have never seen me
before and who are asking yesterday who
the eff is Hank well Hank is an
unincorporated community in central
Donnelly Texas sorry there are some
inside jokes that we just can't let go
of enjoy so for those of you who don't
know why yesterday was a big deal for us
and possibly for Viacom here is a video
you should watch click on it and watch
it and then come back here and finish
watching this video because this video
won't make very much sense otherwise so
important things to know 1 Viacom is
suing YouTube for profiting off of
content that Viacom owned to Viacom says
that YouTube's you have to manually
approve every single video that they put
on youtube.com which is somewhat
problematic because like 24 hours of
video get uploaded to YouTube every
single minute I'm not saying that I
don't want that job I'm just saying that
even the masterminds at Google would
probably have a hard time figuring out
how to then make YouTube make enough
money to not go bankrupt the other
problem with this of course is that
number 3 Viacom says that its video
sharing website spike com is manually
approved all of the content on there is
viewed by a person and approved only if
it does not have copyright infringement
now this is problematic since a huge
majority of the viral category of spike
coms uploaded videos are owned by
independent content creators that did
not give by com the permission to put
their videos on their site with
30-second pre-rolls covered in
advertisements from all angles as of
earlier today among those people whose
videos have been ripped off by Spike com
include my brother John's video on why
Viacom needs to not sue YouTube that is
correct my friends Viacom is happily
monetizing a video made by my brother
about how Viacom happily monetizes
videos that they do not own I don't
really think that there's any
appropriate response to this aside from
possibly extreme frustration but if you
happen to be an intellectual property
attorney can you tell us whether or not
we can sue Viacom cuz it feels like we
should I have spent some time wandering
around Spike calm in the last few days
and man it is a really bad website I
pretty much reverted to my 14 year old
self boobies and violence and viola and
boobies and violins and butts and
boobies and violence and Mountain Dew
apparently some people got stuck at 14
and those people they love spiked calm I
just got a call from John after 300
viacom actually took his video down but
that does not change the fact that I
come just made sixty cents of a video
that they didn't known that is illegal
and it should stop and it should stop on
more than just our video it should stop
on all of the copyrighted videos that
Viacom is putting up on Spike com I
would be perfectly happy suing them for
60 cents if you are a lawyer and you
think that you can do this and you want
to give us maybe 10 hours of your time
please email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com and also have to send a shout
out to all the amazing people who
featured John's video yesterday so thank
you if you are watching this newer
member of the reddit community it is not
every day that you find a community on
the internet that is thoughtful and
respectful and intelligent oh and also I
should mention to everyone if you
already subscribed to me REE YouTube has
a new awesome thing where you can click
on the edit subscription button which is
right up there I think and you can
actually check a little box that has
YouTube email you every time of log
brothers video gets put on the Internet
so if you do that you will be the first
person to see the video all I ask is
that if you are that first person to
watch the video don't leave a comment
saying first I don't want to hear it you
know what Viacom there's no sense crying
over every mistake we're all familiar
with the tragedy of being you but I've
got another meeting maybe we should wrap
this up I'm glad to see you take
constructive criticism well thank you
for your time I know you're busy as hell
but we'll put this thing to bed as we
bash your head open oh we wanna do is
eat your brains we're not unreasonable I
mean
know what's gonna eat your eyes
John I'll see you on Friday lawyers
please email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com
[Music]